la parole est à monsieur bruno belin
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable pour cinq minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre madame la présidente sophie
primas mes chers collègues la commission
de l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable avait été saisie
sur le fond en 2016 nous sommes saisies
pour avis cette année évidemment c'est
un avis que nous avons rendu à travers
un rapport sur lequel pour lequel
évidemment aucun moment donné il a été
remis en question la toxicité des
pesticides évoqué d'ailleurs le projet
de loi ne remet pas en question non plus
ou ne remet pas en cause bien évidemment
l'interdiction généralisée programmé
dans un calendrier précis de ces
substances
au contraire il apporte un certains
nombre d'encadrement je pense notamment
à l'interdiction de replantation de
végétaux attractive pour les insectes
pollinisateurs
je crois que c'est une bonne chose pour
la cause apicole nous avons aussi
évidemment autant dit à travers ce
rapport et à travers les auditions qui
était possible de conduire la cause
agricole et un certain nombre de nos
collègues certains sont présents ont
évidemment démontrer comment cette
filière agricole
comme beaucoup d'autres en france est
fragile gérard en mémoire les
interventions de fer cuyper de pierre
jean verzeaux laine de pierre manuel ou
encore de laurent duplomb qui nous ont
bien expliquer démontrer toute la
fragilité cas encore exprimé là tout à
l'heure la présidente primat de ce
rapport trois points un premier point
monsieur le ministre c'est une volonté
la recherche
vous l'avez dit la prison de primal l'a
redit il faut absolument qu'ils aient un
plan de recherche vous annoncez 7
millions supplémentaires sur le sujet de
la betterave sucrière c'est une bonne
chose
on peut regretter que vous préférez la
réaction à l'anticipation et c'est
dommage malheureusement de réagir dos au
mur alors qu'il aurait pu être fait des
choses peut-être depuis 2016
importe le débat n'est pas de savoir ce
qui aurait dû être fait mais ce que l'on
va faire maintenant dans un qui tient
dans un calendrier pardon bien précis et
ce point de recherche j'y reviendrais
bien yam en conclusion que parce qu'il
est essentiel ça c'est la volonté un sou
est un sou s et une partie de la taxe
alors évidemment c'est un sujet qui
relève de la finance n'est pas forcément
du débat de cet après midi mais qu'une
partie de la taxe sur les pesticides
viennent aider les producteurs les plus
vertueux c'est un souhait c'est comme ça
qu'on n'arrivera peut-être à apporter
une réponse très vite dans le temps et
puis une question je le ministe la
prison de primes à vous la pose est
évidemment au nom de la commission
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable je vous la pose
aussi nous nous interrogeons sur le
regard que le conseil constitutionnel
pourra voir sur l' angle très fermé du
projet de loi mais vous en avez apporté
une bonne réponse et cela relève
évidemment de votre compétence le débat
de cet après midi est essentielle il
réaffirme bien la toxicité des
néonicotinoïdes nous ne revenons pas sur
ce point là c'est un fait scientifique à
qui il prend bien en compte les données
de la filière agricole je crois que
l'agriculture est aussi dans une
transition
vous avez par vos propos devant
l'assemblée nationale monsieur le
ministre soutenu les agriculteurs en
disant combien ils étaient les premiers
évidemment à prendre soin de la terre
qui nous nourrit
je crois que dans notre commission
aménagement du territoire et
développement durable bien sûr nous
faisons du développement durable et nous
faisons de l'aménagement du territoire
il n'ya pas d'aménagement du territoire
sans cause de la ruralité
il n'y a pas de cause de l' erreur était
sans cause de l'agriculture
et puis c'est le dernier point est
vraiment j'insiste là dessus la
recherche
nous sommes le le pays des manuels
charpentier encore dernièrement nous
sommes le pays camille guérin il faut
vraiment que l'on fasse de la recherche
un pan fort du plan de relance il faut
que nous en fassions une ambition elle
sera au service évidemment de l'écologie
est au service de l'environnement
elle sera au service du développement
durable elle sera au service
de l'agriculture et sera au service de
la france je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]